[Music]
1342 chaffee hussain okay well let's go
e4
c5
we know what to do
we play the allop and sicilian that is
our opening
and
it's basically gotten us
better or winning positions out of the
opening in every single game uh up to
this moment
and i just can't stress enough how good
of a choice this is
at this level okay knight c6 is a viable
move but
it's what people often play and if black
isn't careful this can already turn into
an inaccuracy
okay obviously d4
cdcd
yeah now black basically has to play d5
that's the only way to get a viable
position every other move gives us
control of the center and an amazing
position a lot of people play like d6
here
oh there we go
this is a common type of line that
people resort to when they're not too
familiar with the theory but of course
white is better
white is better because now we have
our center is fully intact
we also have the c3 square for the night
and
you know it's just a very pleasant
position now how should we go about
developing
uh which knight should we develop first
and this is
i think a pretty instructive question it
doesn't really matter i mean knight f3
and knight c3 are both totally viable
moves
but i like going knight c3 first because
knight f3 does allow bishop g4
um and why give black
extra options when
when it's not necessary
so
let's start with knight c3
and often it's a good idea to play h3
and the knight f3 just to prevent the
bishop from coming out to g4 and if you
look at black's bishop
it doesn't have
too many good squares other than g4
so h3 is a good attempt to restrict the
bishop and essentially force it to
develop to the far more passive squared
d7
all right so i actually think h3
is is a is a very accurate
move in this position
if that makes sense
where just restricting this bishop as
much as we can
g6
and now we can continue our development
with knight f3
all right so i i can tell that a lot of
people are probably wondering you know
whether d5 is a good move here and i
talked about this in the previous
speedrun game and d5
is not a good move positionally speaking
because it opens up
the fiance bishop so you would only play
it
if you had some you know good follow-up
in mind it's
now i talked about a possible follow-up
to d5 which is to put this dark squared
bishop on d4
in order to disarm uh the black bishop
on g7 so that's definitely a possible
way of handling things you could play d5
here but you know it's really a matter
of taste and i prefer to play simpler
chess let's just develop
uh let's not
worry about overextending our center
just yet i like bishop e3 yeah bishop f4
i don't like for two reasons the first
is that it kind of bites on granite on
d6 the second is that the bishop on f4
is extremely vulnerable uh it can be
attacked with the move e5 it can be
attacked with the move knight h5 now you
don't want your bishop to be
sort of in the middle of things and
walking into all of these annoying
possible moves so bishop b3 is my
preferred developing move we reinforce
our center
and the bishop is very very safe that's
the second
idea of h3 we also stopped knight g4
which otherwise would have been quite
annoying
yeah black is very cramped and it's just
very uncomfortable i mean he doesn't
have control of the center
you know it's
it's just an unpleasant position for
black
now think about where to put this bishop
on f1
do we want to put it on c4 do we want to
put it on well we can't put it on b5
anymore
yeah bishop c4 is a mistake bishop c4 is
a mistake and i know that most of you
guys
like to put your bishop on c4 in general
there's a tactical reason why it's wrong
and then there's a more positional
reason why it's wrong
the does anybody know what the tactical
reason is and this has occurred in our
speedrun many many times across many
different types of positions i've talked
about this
very important concept
um anita got it and little mentor got it
knight takes e4 folks
knight takes e4 and then d5 winning back
the piece with interest i'll talk more
about this after the game
um but the second reason is that we walk
into moves like b5 that bishop on c4 is
just quite vulnerable just like the
bishop on f4 by the way
so i much prefer to put the bishop on d3
i like this way of developing the
bishops are controlling and reinforcing
the center pawns
and that gives us the freedom to operate
on both sides of the board without
having to worry
that our center is somehow going to
collapse okay so b5
no action is required on our part i mean
b4 is not a serious
idea because we can just go 92
and in fact that overextends black quite
a bit
uh there's a proposal for e5 i i don't
really get that move i mean black will
take and go knight back to d7 and then
our pawn 95 is going to be a weakness so
again you don't need to reinvent the
wheel just complete the development with
castles
no knight takes b5 doesn't work knight
takes b5 a b bishop takes b5 first of
all there's queen a5 track winning the
bishop
second of all black just played bishop
d7 on pinning
knight b4 is also not dangerous we can
just drop our bishop back to e2 and then
play a3
it's just not not dangerous
okay so we have multiple ways of
handling this position
um we can play the move queen d2 a lot
of you are proposing queen d2
with the potential idea of trading the
fiance bishop of bishop h6 but
i kind of like playing on the queen side
in this position there is a move that if
you play the rya lopez this idea occurs
very frequently now the c3 knight
can eventually make its way to g3
um but playing 92 here doesn't make as
much sense we can throw in a move that
actually forces black to damage the
queen side a little bit and that move is
a4
this provokes b4
and then we maneuver our knight to g3
and the pawn on b4 is going to be
a pretty it's not a big weakness but
it's another headache for black to worry
about and if black follows up with a5
that creates a hole on the b5 square
which we could potentially occupy with
our bishop and it kind of dries up the
queen side making it harder for black
to create counter play on that side of
the board and it gives us once again the
freedom to operate on the king side and
i'm going to show you guys how we're
going to do that
okay
so we're expecting b4 i mean b takes a4
would be very weird here
uh that would leave the a6 pawn quite
weak and it would give us excellent
queen side play
so hopefully this makes sense the logic
behind this move i hope it makes sense
this is a positional move
okay knight a7 whoa
whoa
that is bad
i mean i guess
he didn't want to play b4 for whatever
reason but this just blunders the pawn i
don't really get it
because e4 is not hanging
i think that's a free pawn i mean just a
takes b5 yeah that was a weird move
and after atx b5 we can play knight
takes b5
notice that the e4 pawn hangs in that
line but so does the a7 knight
after atxb5 the funny thing is we have
an even better move than knight takes b5
i think
okay so this is a very instructive
moment because i would say 95 percent of
people would take on b5 immediately
and i wouldn't fault you for that and
that does win a pawn
but if you follow through on that line
knight takes b5 knight takes b5
bishop takes b5 check
black can cover the check with his
knight
and after that
black israel is still ready to castle
kingside and you know he's limited the
damage to a pawn but there's actually a
better move here we can
you know that knight on a7 is
tremendously vulnerable i'm looking at
the knight i'm seeing that it's a type
two undefended piece and it's being
pressured by the rook so what idea comes
to mind so not e5
e5 gives away the d5 square if you go e5
black will go knight d5
and stabilize the situation on the
center
don't forget that when you push upon in
the center you often give away an
important square in return
the move is d5 this accomplishes three
things well two things first of all look
at this bishop on b7 it blunts the
bishop
yes it opens up the other bishop but
that's a worthy price to pay but the
main thing is that we're piling up on
the knight the knight doesn't have any
good squares if it moves back to c8 i
mean just look at how passive that is
after bishop takes b5 check we can
develop massive pressure on this uh on
the queen side it's just very clear even
intuitively that this version of winning
the pawn is a lot better
now there is this move b4 oh which he
just played
and
we kind of cut a corner i didn't ask you
guys to find a response to this move
but it is quite important to to have a
response in mind what should we do
what should we do here
so the obvious approach is to take on a7
and then to take on c3 and once again
yes that wins a pawn but there is
a much better move very good queen a4
check is that move
this not only wins the pawn but it
potentially just wins the game i mean if
you look at black's minor pieces they're
all essentially just going to be hanging
after black responds to the check
there's also this very creative move
knight c6 here
um covering the check and opening up an
attack on the queen but it doesn't work
and if he plays it then we will
respond accordingly knight d7 okay
so obviously now we don't take on a7 we
take the pawn on p4 and simultaneously
attacking both of black's queen side
minor pieces
queen b8 i think is the only way to
defend at the moment
but man oh man does that look
terrible for black
my guess is he's gonna find it
yeah this is this is just a disaster
this is a disaster
but good stuff by our opponent you can
see that already at this level people
are capable of finding
you know good defensive moves everything
isn't that easy so
how do we approach this position what is
the priority well the top priority for
me when i look at this is to say if we
can prevent black from castling if we
can force black's king to remain in the
center
then
you know we're likelier to win the game
faster i mean if we left by castle then
at the very least you know black will be
on the road to very slowly consolidating
now it's not so easy to prevent castles
because
you might come up with the move queen a4
but queen a4 potentially walks into a
discovered attack right i mean it allows
moves like knight c8
now then you might say well what about
bishop b5 let's pin the knight on d7 and
i think that is
thinking in the right direction
that is thinking in the right direction
but it's the wrong execution
when you play bishop b5 you give up a
very valuable
light squared bishop you want that
bishop to sit on b5
and pin the knight you don't want it to
be captured
so you can play bishop takes a7 and then
bishop b5 that's a very viable move or
as some of you are pointing out you can
play knight b5
and that is the move that i actually
prefer in this position
essentially forcing a trade
then our bishop lands on b5 and this is
the ideal version we are preventing
castling and our bishop is totally
unassailable here
now not totally unassailable there is an
interesting idea for black we'll see if
he finds it
but it i believe that it doesn't work
you can think about what i'm talking
about in the meantime black does have a
way to try to contest this bishop
tactically
yeah bishop a6 but i feel like we have
multiple options against bishop a6 and
we'll cross that bridge when we get
there
now you might be looking at this and
saying wait a minute why are we giving
up our good night for blacks bad night
and this is all about setting priorities
right
you can't make an omelet without
breaking some eggs and it's more
important here to stop black from
castling
than you know to to preserve black's
weak minor pieces i feel like this is
gonna this is likelier to give us the
quick win
because now the knight on d7 is caught
on the crossfire
so this whole idea of
sometimes it's okay to violate
positional principles such as trading a
bad piece for a good one or a good one
for a bad one rather
if
you know if you're attending to your
tactical goals
because the concrete considerations in
the position always are more important
than
following general principles and as we
hit 1400 1500
that
concept becomes a lot more important you
can't just operate based on oh this is a
good piece that's a bad piece therefore
i can't trade it you have to put more
thought into the position than that yeah
bishop a6
bishop a6 we have multiple moves i think
it's the best move in the position for
black i do think bishop a6 is the best
move
okay but he doesn't play it queen c7
understandable move
because it protects the knight and
prepares castling but
at a moment's notice you should see that
the queen is incredibly vulnerable here
and we can we can chase the queen with
rook c1
but what is the best version
uh of that move and in fact we have a
much better move than roxy one i think
we have a really really pretty
tactical sequence
now let me just take a second to work it
out
yeah we have a really nice move here who
sees it very nice bishop b6 i think
bishop b6 is the best move
bishop b6 uses the pin then i can't
capture and if the queen takes the
bishop then we take on d7 and we win the
queen boom
this is the crushing move
because it forces the queen back and
then we can go rook c1 with totally
decisive effect
yeah just being alert to to tactics and
not always going for the the most
obvious move although of course
obviously
rook c1 here is completely winning as
well
um it's completely winning as well in
fact roxy won queen d8 we could then go
bishop b6 and maybe that's even a better
version
than going bishop b6 immediately it
really doesn't matter
it's all totally winning
no rook first was not bad and again
everything is winning in this position
black is way too cramped there's way too
many tactical
uh there's way too many problems in
black's position
so think about what we're going to do in
the event of queen b8 we do have a
forced win
if queen v8 happens
and it might not be the easiest move to
find because
you might be thinking of trying to win
the knight on d7
but after queen b8 the best move is to
actually capture it and to transform the
advantage right we captured the knight
we get the king out into the open and
then we throw in a check on b5 and that
essentially leads to mate
so yeah this is important too right when
you have a pin
you should always consider taking the
pinned piece because that can allow you
in certain circumstances to transform
your advantage bishop takes d7 is the
fastest path to checkmate
now queen now the king wants to drop
back to e8 so we prevent it from doing
so
and we force it onto the c file where
it's going to get checkmated by the rook
yeah best move would be king of fate
here technically but who's who's going
to play that
black would much rather resign
yeah it's all over bishop c6 queen takes
c6 is just checkmate
okay
doesn't matter which rook we put there
it's made in two either way
it really doesn't matter
whoa and it makes waves thank you for
the gift
bishop c6 queen takes c6 it's me
simple and very strong and once again
look at the kind of position that the
aleppo gave us
it gave us a brilliant position with a
full center
and it allows us to play these kinds of
games
cool stuff let's go over the game
okay
so
yeah knight c64
okay so essentially
this is
viable i mean it's not the worst thing
that black can play but it's far from
the best
and
i know a great sock fan and and a lot of
people just don't know that the best
moves here are d5 and knight f6 they
play this the same way that they play
the open sicilian which is what makes
the alpine so effective
okay so 1964 it takes takes d6
yeah knight c3
now
just for those interested in tactical
tricks
knight f3 does contain
a a very nasty potential idea does
anybody know
what i'm talking about after bishop g4
we have an attempt
that can result in a very quick win if
black is not aware of this
what move am i talking about and what's
the associated trap
not bishop c4
although bishop c4 does create the
threat of bishop takes f7 yeah d5
and most people will automatically play
95 here
as you guys know
knight takes e5 wins the game because
the bishop hangs
bishop takes d1 there's bishop e5 check
and the most in my opinion the most
well-known instance of that trap is in
the queen's gambit declined
and a lot of people actually get caught
by this bishop g5
and now you can start with knight bd7
and it's the same exact principle white
takes on d5 knight takes d5
i think most people know this one bishop
before check
and at the end of the day you're up a
piece
there is a lot of
a lot of traps that involve this general
idea but in this video we're not playing
for trap so i decided to go for knight
c3
knight f6 and
still still we could play knight f3 and
d5
uh here it's not as effective because
after 95 knight takes e5
black does have the possibility of
playing d takes e5 and averting disaster
although of course this pawn structure
is not desirable
after queen b3 this is
already very bad so in a classical game
i would probably go knight f3 without h3
but i just want to show you that
i wanted to show you that this is an
effective way of restricting the
mobility of the bishop
okay so g6 is good our opponent
developed well i mean this is the
correct way for black to develop
and i even like a6b5
now remember that in a position like
this
a4 is a double-sided
sword
on the one hand yes it stops b5 on the
other hand it creates a very big hole on
b4
it creates a very big call on b4
and uh this hole can be occupied by
black's knight
so i feel like in many cases it's
actually a better idea to allow v5
than to prevent it and weaken your
square like this
and i remember many many years ago i had
a game which i later ended up winning
due to a blunder but i made a very
similar type of mistake where i
i played the move a4 thinking that i'm
preventing
queen side expansion but i i didn't
realize how meaningful that whole lineup
on before would be
let me see if i can find that game for
you
yeah
so this is an instructive game and it
was a game in the alapan actually so
i practice what i preach
as you can see world youth under
10 i was about 1800 at the time this
game was played
so my opponent knew what to do d5
and for a while we followed the main
line of the elephant castles bishop e3
cdcd bishop b7
and this is
classic isolated queen pun position
rook c1 castle squint d2 this is all
normal
okay so here my opponent plays a6 thank
you christian for the raid party of 37
great match
okay so what do you think i played in
this position
what do you think i played in this
position
1599 is just uh neither of us had feed a
ratings at the time and that was the
default
uh so that wasn't actually my rating
yeah i played a4 automatically
i just automatically played a4 without
thinking about it
and
of course as you can see this creates a
massive hole in b4 and b5 wasn't even a
dangerous idea because it weakens the c6
knight
so
my opponent could have already gone
knight before and then swung the knight
back to d5 to blockade the isolated
queen pun but instead he played rook d8
rook c8
and ultimately
i mean he punishes me because now the
knight aims for b3
i want knight b5 trying to use tactics
to trade off that knight
but no he goes queen before and the end
game is just terrible for me i mean look
at this
okay this is a transmission error he
didn't actually play bishop g4 obviously
uh but we eventually yeah this is the
actual position
and i'm completely lost in this end game
but eventually my opponent blottered a
piece
okay knight f6 check final attempt and
he went g7
and and watered on d6 so i got lucky but
uh the point remains a4
uh automatically is i mean you should
never play it for automatically
now it's not the same here but still i
don't like a4 so bishop d3b5 castles
uh some of you were proposing knight
takes b5 this does not work for two
reasons the first is queen a5 check the
second is bishop d7
okay yeah he had time he just blundered
it was just a blunder
uh others were thinking about e5 and
yeah you should always consider a move
like e5 in these positions of course
i just don't think it works concretely
right d-e-d-e-97
and yeah i can play bishop e4 but black
defends the knight and i'm just not sure
that this is a transformation in white's
favor now what should you do in a
position like this if you're already
losing this pawn
then you should probably play e6 if
you're giving the pawn away you might as
well ruin black structure but this is
not impressive black is up upon and he's
completed his development so
this is just not something that i'm a
big fan of if you've got such a nice
position to begin with
castles bishop b7 and here comes a4
now of course b4 is
forced i mean he had to play b4
and then the idea that
i would have carried out is to get this
knight over to g3
and now the follow-up plan is queen d2
followed by bishop h6 which
all of you are aware of and i was
talking about this and later on the
knight could sacrifice itself on f5
in many situations that's exactly what
hap what ends up happening so uh so
ultimately white can play on both sides
of the board here the queen said you
could play rook c1
and uh but the main idea is to play on
the king side and black just doesn't
have a good plan here black's position
is cramped there's no targets
and that's why i enjoy these positions
so much and they really teach you how to
play uh how to play solid fundamentally
sound chess
all right
so knight a7 is just inexplicable abab
and now d5 improving on knight takes b5
not playing automatically b4 queen a4
check
now knight c6
was a tricky possibility who can tell me
what white should
how white should respond to this move
and why it has to be accurate here
queen b5 is correct yeah you just play
queen b5 very cold-blooded move and if
bc
yeah you can i mean the simplest is
probably just d takes e6 and black's
position collapses you're threatening
the bishop and the bishop can't move
back because you give away the run
so
yeah knight a7 was abysmal and after 97
queen takes before
queen began this was maybe the most
important moment of the game the move
knight b5 trading a good piece for a bad
piece
but in return
uh getting a situation where
uh black is
totally pinned
head to foot now bishop a6 was
definitely the only way to stay in the
game uh every other move loses on the
spot including his move queen c7 what
would we have done against bishop basics
uh well
i think that white has several
approaches
just give me a second to think about
this
what is the most accurate move
yeah rook a5 is rook a5 is one
possibility
but but then black castles if you play
rook a5 black castles although i guess
after rook fa1 no here black is busted
here black is busted because the bishop
can't move back you lose the knight and
if bishop takes b5 then rook takes a8 so
maybe rook a5
is the path forward bishop takes rook
takes
and i guess black can forcibly castle by
playing queen d8 but obviously this is
uh this is atrocious for black as well
so rook a5 is
is one option
uh i was contemplating queen a4 that's
another option
a bishop takes d7 i don't think it wins
a piece bishop takes d7 king takes d7 i
don't know what the follow-up is
i don't think it wins a piece if you
play queen a4 check here black will
cover with bishop b5 i think that's what
a lot of you are missing you think that
you can play queen a4 and then get the
queen of c6
no but queen takes b rook takes b and
already black is fine here
because you're attacking the rook you're
attacking the b pawn now you definitely
don't want to take on d7
you definitely don't want to take on d7
here
does that make sense because that gives
that truly does give away the good piece
and it gives black counter play
um
you can also play a very creative move
here knight t4
the point is that you're defending the
bishop you're aiming for c6 and if black
takes it
you take with the queen and black and
resign because you hit the rook on a
chain
and now you're threatening bishop takes
a6
no it's okay i mean bishop d7 has to be
considered and you're absolutely right
to contemplate this move but you have to
be concrete
in any case bishop a6
would have kept black in the game for
the time being but queen c7
is swiftly punished bishop b6 just using
the pin
and yeah roxy one was also very much
possible queen the eight and now bishop
b6 is just as strong
it's just as strong
why not rook takes a six well then black
takes
i'm not sure what your follow-up is and
remember that the queen is pinned
so you can't simply take on a6
okay
so
queen c7 bishop b6 queen b8 and now
transforming the pin into checkmate
taking on d7 and going rick c1 check a
very simple game but nonetheless there
were stuff happening on the queen side
and i think this moment when we played
a4 was quite instructive when you cause
problems for your opponent like this at
this level people still really struggle
to solve them properly
thank you guys appreciate it um thanks
again for the support
good night
[Music]